[Music]
early morning in mainland Europe two
white vans are quietly being loaded full
of cocaine Ashish an ecstasy they're
being ready to move nearly four tons of
narcotics authorities have been trying
for decades to contain the global trade
in illicit drugs the drugs in these vans
will be taken to an incinerator and
destroyed
it's a journey the Portuguese police
make every month and they know there's
no end in sight our job is to try to
make it as hard as possible for the drug
traffickers to sell their product but
it's not a fight that we can win this is
the story of how one country sparked a
global movement for change
[Music]
at a Portuguese incineration plant the
drug squad prepares to burn their latest
haul for years Portugal took a hard line
approach to drugs
the policy was that all people caught
with drugs regardless of the amount and
even if they wore for their own personal
use will be legally prosecuted as drug
traffickers they will be brought into
court and they may be sentenced to some
time in prison but the hardline approach
didn't make a difference regarding
people stopping use drugs in the 1990s
drug use spread to every part of society
in this small European country one in
every hundred of the population were
believed to be addicted to heroin
simply incinerating their supply was no
answer the country needed to forge a
radical new approach to drugs in 2001
Portugal came up with a policy that
would put its people first a new law
enables citizens to possess small
amounts of any illegal drug it would no
longer be a criminal offense for mostly
casual users to enjoy their vice of
choice state resources could be focused
on addict's instead of being punished
for their dependency they'd be offered
help that it was old Factory and they
are using their psychologists Maria and
Raquel a state-funded outreach workers
everyday they visit drug users to offer
clean needles smoking pipes and advice
they call this approach harm reduction
we respect their space you know we are
not like come on get to treatment so you
have to stop it's not what we say you
know in their time if they want we we
help them to go to treatment
decriminalization has removed much of
the stigma addicts felt and the fear of
prosecution that stopped them from
seeking help it's easy to them to get to
us and say ok I have a drug problem and
I need help they don't have to lie to us
it's it's like ok I'm using and I'm not
afraid to get get in jail or something
like that and I think this is a big big
difference you know
[Music]
90% of Portugal's anti-drugs resources
are now spent on treatment and
prevention 10% on policing and
punishment in the United States it's the
opposite side to my talks of Indian
cinema twinsen intimidated
but the Hoopoe was wanted in 5% opinion
he did know I stood up for the Cape's
wanna say shake up sua since
decriminalization drug-induced deaths
have dropped from 80 in 2001 to just 16
in 2012 over the same period the total
number of heroin addicts and haft
Portugal's experiment defied the fears
of opponents and broke a global policy
taboo but for all its success the new
approach did nothing to address the
supply side of the drugs trade though
citizens weren't now being arrested for
possessing drugs
the police were still chasing their
dealers globally criminal gangs and
drugs cartels continued to dominate a
drugs trade with over 300 billion
dollars
[Music]
the countries where those drugs
originated continued to pay the price
they've been paying for over a quarter
of a century in the Colombian capital
Bogota the polls opened with a minute's
silence for the three candidates killed
during the presidential campaign it was
the culmination of weeks of terror
the man expected to win is the Liberal
Party's Cesar Gaviria he arrived
surrounded by bodyguards and a media
posse he's pledged to continue the
present administration's hardline
against the drug cartels the cartels in
Colombia by 1990 became almost
all-powerful Escobar was able to do
terrorism in a way that only probably
bin Laden has been able blowing up
buildings and bringing down planes and
killing policemen one by one he was
really a threat to Colombian democracy
they were scaring times
when he won the election Gaviria vowed
to take on the cartels in his own way
you have to fight CalSTRS you have to
militarize the whole thing to show that
these people could go to jail at that
moment we had to do it
cavalry oversaw the dismantling of
Colombia's drugs cartels and the killing
of their most infamous leader Pablo
Escobar
[Music]
but after four years in office he seemed
to have made little lasting impact
whereas once they grew coca plants for
cocaine production now it's poppy seeds
one kilo of heroin sells in New York for
$160,000 ten times the price of cocaine
the war on drugs really fail and at the
end what you see is no matter what you
do the drugs gets to the US the life of
Colombia has been really really
difficult we have suffered so much
violence you have to look for a way out
you have to look for a solution we know
that just repression just prohibitionism
doesn't work we know it for certain we
had lived that the drug producing
countries of Latin America are following
the lead of Portugal and demanding
change
but it's the country that began the war
on drugs the might just bring it to an
end here in America they're now selling
marijuana in the mall this one's gonna
be a little more earthy definitely a
really good strength in 2014
Colorado became the first US state to
fully legalize cannabis within a year it
had already become a 700 million dollar
business there among the new industries
biggest players medicine man is
testament to the growing impacts of a
new breed of cannabis capitalists when
my brother and I started this and my
cousin Frank was our first employee and
we stood right outside the doors outside
here and we said what do we want to be
and by the end of that discussion he
said we want to be that Costco of
marijuana and at the time we were really
thinking of only cultivation now we're
the leader in this industry in Colorado
and our vision has changed so now we
want to be the Costco of cultivation and
the Starbucks of retail in the last year
we did about nine million this year
we'll do about eighteen million dollars
in business Anandi's purpose-built plant
50 different marijuana strains are grown
trimmed dried and cured to develop their
flavor and potency its cultivation on an
industrial scale yet Colorado law
requires every plant to be tracked
throughout the process from seed to sale
[Music]
legal controls are helping move
marijuana away from the black market and
into mainstream society just as you
would see somebody having a casual drink
on a patio you might see somebody around
the corner just taking a quick hit of
Bowl
[Music]
welcome to the joint ruling class once
you feel like you've got enough there
slowly start rolling it between and move
your fingers in slowly in one room they
had they taught you how to roll a joint
which is really cool I rolled my first
joint today it was pretty awesome and
then after that they taught us how to
roll our own sushi which was really cool
it's kind of great a great mix of people
everyone was really friendly hello hi
[Music]
testament to just how mainstream
marijuana has become is the
fastest-growing part of the industry
known as edibles there's a plethora of
food and drink products designed to
appeal to a public who may never have
smoked infused with cannabis oil edibles
offer an example of how legalization
enabled regulation in 2014
Colorado introduced strict new rules on
the packaging and potency of these
products for the industry it's become a
necessary part of building trust with
the public December of 2013 a couple of
leaders in Colorado came out and gave
warnings that reefer madness was about
to ensue in Colorado and that people
said whoa boy kids are going to be using
marijuana in great numbers and shortly
after legalization they hadn't retract
what they said
[Music]
initial research a suggested marijuana
use by teenagers actually fell meanwhile
the state reaped revenues of 76 million
dollars from fees and taxes on marijuana
sales that set to rise to nearly a
hundred million dollars in 2016 and with
it
the funding of schools and the police
it's been a marked for another great
benefit about this industry is choking
out the black market whether that's the
cartels or or organized crime we are
taking their customers from them and
we're gonna choke them out to almost
non-existing
Colorado's experience helped to trigger
a momentum for change across the United
States
almost half of American states have now
taken some steps to legalize and
regulate cannabis many many people still
say well we don't know what will happen
if this is free if we decriminalize the
production and the consumption of drugs
they they should look at Portugal and
Colorado today is a very legitimate
issue I have no doubt that the world is
going to move to regulation instead of
prohibition is about abandoning
something that does work fourteen years
ago
Portugal's experiments at a bold new
path for dealing with drugs the shift it
prompted could be about to reach a
critical global mass
[Music]